but first let's go straight to central
London now and speak to the housing
secretary Robert generic thank you very
much for being on the program this
morning mr. generator woody now the
Prime Minister has said that the NHS
will be overwhelmed unless people start
so she's socially distancing right now
saying that people shouldn't go and see
their mums on Mother's Day it's a pretty
bleak warning what exactly is it that we
all need to do well the figures that
we're seeing coming out of countries
like Italy are very sobering and we all
now need to follow the medical advice so
that we can turn the tide on this virus
the advice is clear we need to stay at
home to protect the NHS and in doing so
we will save lives and so today we're
taking a further very significant step
the chief medical officer has identified
a group of individuals across the
country for specific medical reasons
underlying health conditions are
particularly at risk of coronavirus and
we're writing to these people that's
around 1.5 million people in England and
we're asking them as soon as practicable
to stay at home and to do so for a
prolonged period perhaps as long as 12
weeks and I know if this is you and
you're listening to the program you will
be worried by this and I know you'll be
thinking about the practicalities how
can you get access to food and to
medicines and remain in contact with the
outside world and so we want you to know
that you might be saying at home for a
long period of time but you will not be
alone we're going to do whatever it
takes to support you do you need to be
at home on your own if you're one of
these people identified
well if you have a partner or a person
that you live with then you'll continue
to live at home in the usual setting
we're not expecting families to be
broken up as a result of this but this
will be a big challenge for these
individuals we appreciate that and
that's why for those people who don't
have family and friends and neighbors at
their side to help them we're putting in
place other measures so the NHS will be
delivering medicines to these people
through the community pharmacy network
and I've been working with councils with
supermarkets and with the Armed Forces
to ensure that food and other basic
supplies can be delivered to the
doorstep of these people hundreds of
thousands of people across the country
for as long as it takes
some people be wondering why the
government hasn't stepped in on food
supplies a bit earlier I mean we've all
seen the empty shelves and supermarkets
will struggle to get the online
deliveries yesterday the government said
that a billion pounds we have a billion
pounds more food in our homes than we do
usually why is this only happening now
well I've seen what it's like in
supermarkets and I can only imagine how
it feels if you've come off a long shift
in the NHS or working in social care and
you go to the supermarket and see that
there is enough food in the system we
have a very resilient food sector but we
all need to behave responsibly and
considerately
that isn't happening in all cases today
and we need to make sure that happens
supermarkets are best place to take
action and put in place specific systems
and schemes in their own stores knowing
their customers and what's going on on
the ground and many are doing that
helping the elderly - you have specific
times a day to go shopping or have
special schemes in place for NHS and
social care workers and I strongly
support that but I really urge members
of the public to behave responsibly if
you just shop for you and your family
needs there will be plenty of food for
other people and their families we've
been very clear this morning on what you
should do if you're at this at-risk
category and what I just want to explore
now
it's what everybody else should do what
we should all do because I feel like
some of the messaging has been slightly
confused Forrest Johnson today saying
that you shouldn't be visiting your mum
on Mother's Day today but then on Friday
he was asked if he would see his mother
on Mother's Day and he said he'd
certainly be sending her my very best
wishes and hope to get to see her how is
the public's supposed to know what to do
when the messaging seems to be changing
on a daily basis well we're always
following the expert medical advice and
we have access to the best advice in the
world and we're implementing the
different measures in our action plan at
the right time for the UK the advice
today is very clear we need to stay at
home all by our the most essential
activities and we by doing that will
protect the NHS and help to save lives
so I know it's Mother's Day and I know
it's tough and it goes against
everything that we want to do as a
family but don't go and see your mum
give her a phone call Skype her FaceTime
her tell her that you love her and that
we're going to get through this together
you see I can't help thinking that it
feels as if we are paying playing
catch-up here we only ordered pubs
restaurants cafes to close on Friday
schools were just shut this week and yet
we've known about coronavirus in China
since January we've seen what's
happening in Italy Italy could say that
they didn't know what was coming but we
don't have that excuse so why were these
things not implemented sooner well from
the outset of this crisis we set out all
of the measures that are available to us
in our action plan and those are very
similar measures to other countries that
the other countries have implemented but
we said that we would follow the expert
advice and we would bring each one in
turn into place at the right moment for
this country different countries are at
different stages and the nature of the
virus means that it will take some time
a couple of weeks before we start to see
the effect of the measures that we have
implemented and the ones that we're
implementing now yesterday or Friday the
prime minister announced that bars pubs
and clubs those places where people come
together to meet others in a very social
setting
should now close and that's happened and
today we're saying that this group of
particularly vulnerable people
this 1.5 million individuals should now
stay at home for the duration until
we've turned the tide on the virus I
think the advice is very clear to
members of the public today unless
you're a key worker unless you're going
to work to do something that's
absolutely essential you should now be
staying at home and in doing so we will
protect the NHS we will help to flatten
the curve and will save lives you say
that you should now be staying at home I
just want to ask on behalf of parents of
young children for example how practical
is that I used to label to take your
child to the playground for example well
we've said that you have to balance
staying at home with continuing to stay
fit and healthy so you can go out for
walks you can enjoy the countryside
you can try to to stay fit and healthy
by exercising but you have to do that in
a very responsible way and that means
staying a few meters out that means
staying a few meters away from other
people it doesn't mean having play dates
with other children or coming into a lot
of social contact with others so I think
parents will have to balance this
carefully people shouldn't be crowding
together in parks you are better off
outside then you would be inside but we
all have to behave very responsibly
whilst we're doing this but this is
going to be for quite a long period of
time and so it's important that people
do try to get some exercise and to stay
healthy but to do so following the clear
public health England guidance is it
acceptable to take my child to a
playground or do we not know the
guidance that we've set out says that
you can do exercise you can go for walks
you can go to a playground but you
shouldn't be trying to get into contact
with other people and other children so
if you're doing it try to have make your
children stay a couple of metres away
from others and behaviors responsibly as
they can do lots of people sat out
together in parks or on beaches and so
on that isn't sensible we strongly
discourage that but people going out for
walks
their children just as a family unit
staying where for possible a couple of
metres away from others that's fine and
it's probably the right thing to do
because you've got to maintain as fit
and health as we can do join this period
okay it's interesting hey and were you
talking about strongly discouraging
people from doing things because despite
the prime minister pleading with people
not to do it we've all seen those images
of people going out for a last pint on
Friday night
the reports of hundreds of thousands of
people visiting skegness on Saturday are
you worried that people are not behaving
responsibly and if people continue to do
so could we see a lockdown similar to
those experienced in other countries in
Europe well we don't want to go down
that route you know we want to live in a
free society where we can continue to go
about activities whilst following the
medical advice but this isn't again this
is very serious people need to follow
that advice we have now closed the pubs
the restaurants the clubs the indoor
gyms and leisure activities and we want
people now to follow that advice and
stay at home wherever possible anything
don't if people then clearly will have
to consider if people don't follow that
advice will clearly have to consider
other options but none of us want to go
down that route okay now I just want to
talk about the National Health Service
so we were talking earlier in the
interview about the situation in Italy
you may have seen the graph that the FT
is producing showing that deaths are
happening happening at a quicker rate in
the United Kingdom even than in Italy
where over 4,000 people have already
died the prime minister said today the
Italians have a superb healthcare system
yet their doctors and nurses had been
overwhelmed is our NHS ready
well I want to thank everybody who's
working in the NHS and in social care
and in the other frontline areas of
government like my own in in local
government where local officers are
working around the clock to put in place
the measures that they need this is
going to be a huge effort it's going to
require a heroic national effort really
to get us through this capacity is
increasing the NHS is discharging
patients to build more capacity our call
to arms for people who've left the NHS
to come back is succeeding within just
the first 48 hours of that we've seen
thousands of doctors and nurses coming
forward and that's fantastic we signed a
really important deal with the private
sector yesterday which will bring
forward thousands of more hospital beds
and almost 20,000 additional health care
professionals and put those together at
the service of the NHS as one national
team so we're doing all the things we
can but let's be clear the numbers are
rising we need to follow the the advice
of the healthcare professionals and it's
only by doing that if everyone plays
their part that will begin to turn the
tide
how about ventilators that's another
important part of the fight and last
Sunday that hand Court told me that we
had 5000 but needed many times that have
we made a progress that we have since we
made the call to British industry last
week we've been overwhelmed by offers of
support and there's now a number of
manufacturers who are working with us we
were in receipt of some of the first
prototypes and we expect that
manufacturing can start quite quickly
we're up to I think 12,000 ventilators
now the deal with the private sector
brings an additional 1,000 ventilators
to it to bear on the situation but we do
need more and we're trying to ramp up
production as quickly as we can and NHS
workers of course are on the front line
of this fight you described their
efforts as heroic I think we can all
probably agree with that well today
nearly 4,000 staff have written a letter
in The Sunday Times pleading with a
prime minister to make sure they've got
the right protective equipment and they
say frontline doctors have been telling
us
weeks that they don't feel safe at work
GPS have told us that they feel
abandoned I mean that's a disgrace
doesn't it absolutely everybody who is
on the front line supporting us as a
country through this crisis must have
the equipment that they need to do their
job and to be personally protected we're
working very hard with success to get
more PPE available we've dig by this
afternoon we will have delivered more
supplies to hospitals across the country
we've delivered supplies to GP surgeries
and to pharmacies and next week all
social care providers will receive
further supplies do you accept
manufacturing and importing large
quantities I think in recent days we've
received three million masks for example
but I completely accept there's more to
do we're manufacturing and importing
more and we need to get that to the
front line as quickly as possible
do you accept though that it's been too
slow
I think there's a lot more that we need
to do we are getting more supplies to
the frontline as I say not just to
hospitals very important though that is
but also to others like the GPS the
pharmacists the social care providers to
those working in homeless shelters and
hostels for example we're doing that
more supplies will flow this coming week
and we're keeping it constantly under
review working around the clock to get
those supplies out to the people who
really need them okay and I'm keen to
ask you about the economic support
package it was unveiled by the
Chancellor earlier this week really
unprecedented economic support package
particularly aimed at people who are
working for employers that will be hit
by coronavirus but lots of people have
pointed out that it doesn't really seem
to do very much for the 5 million people
who are self employed in the United
Kingdom many of them will be really
worried about their jobs can we expect
more help for self-employed people in
the coming days
well we published an unprecedented set
of measures last week which is a very
comprehensive set of measures to support
businesses to support families and
individuals we appreciate that it's not
perfect and there may be more things
that we need to do the Chancellor is
keeping it constantly under review and
is considering what more we might be
able to do for the self-employed but we
have taken steps to support them whether
that's through injecting 7 billion
pounds more into the welfare system
whether it's through Universal Credit or
employment support and other things that
we're doing as well for example helping
to give them more cash flow by
supporting them with their mortgage
holders or if they're renters it is more
complicated for the self-employed than
it is for employees it is logistically
operationally very difficult to
replicate a scheme like we've done for
employed individuals the 80 percent
salary guarantee up to two and a half
thousand pounds a month
but there if if we need to do more we
will do it and the Chancellor's keeping
this under review